un petit parc devant le palais de
justice de Manhattan coupé en deux
[Applaudissements]
d'un côté des partisans de Donald Trump
venu le soutenir
et de l'autre c'est des tracteurs qui ne
peuvent le sentir
entre les deux des clôtures et des
policiers pour éviter la front main
un parc à l'image d'un pays déchiré
des divisions qui s'étalent au grand
jour
face à la justice
ça suffit
le meilleur président que je payais
connu affirme Kristen Chapman les
démocrates n'ont jamais été inquiété
pour leur crime dégoûtant
de la clôture les affaires espèrent que
la justice permettra de clore un
chapitre sombre de l'histoire de son
pays
ce n'est pas un secret que c'est un
homme méchant fait du tort dit-elle et
sa matrice de voir des gens qui croient
ses mensonges et qui défendent ce
criminels
le procureur accuse finalement ancien
président d'avoir fait 34 fausses
déclarations pour cacher des crimes
pendant que les entreprennent célèbrent
[Applaudissements]
c'est partisans son révoltés
ça parce qu'ils ne veulent pas qu'il
gagne
c'est New York est devenu le centre du
monde politique au médiatique l'espace
d'un après-midi l'événement semble avoir
laissé de marbre les New Yorkais Marie
curry qui savoure sa première journée de
retraite a préféré rester loin de ce
cirque
les New Yorkais n'aiment pas Trump
respectent-elles les New Yorkais sont
occupés à vivre et ça c'est une
distraction et une nuisance
ici Jean-François Bélanger Radio-Canada
New York